what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some pretty juicy
details about Avengers the King Dynasty
and Avengers Secret Wars now the next
movie in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that is coming out is Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania and in this movie
it's going to set up Avengers the Kang
Dynasty and it's going to show us
exactly who King the Conqueror is and
also show us some of his variants as
well and variants are going to be a
major part of the Kang Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars and I'm not just
talking about Good variants either we
are going to see some evil variants of
certain characters that we probably love
now this isn't going to be like Doctor
Strange in the Multiverse of Madness
where we only saw a few different
variants it's not going to be like that
secret Wars is going to have a ton of
different variants and hopefully played
by a lot of cool different actors and it
looks like we know how exactly all of
these variants are going to come
together in Avengers Secret Wars and
what causes them to come together the
events and the Kang Dynasty and that's
what we're going to be breaking down
today now just a heads up these are
leaks slash rumors and I am going to be
adding a theory of my own and if any of
this ends up being true there will be
some spoilers for the King Dynasty and
Avengers Secret Wars so this is your
official spoiler alert now as I
mentioned before there's an order of
events here that needs to happen and the
first one is Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania like I said this will
introduce us to a few different variants
of King but most importantly this will
introduce us to the main variant of Kang
the king the Conqueror who was going to
end up being the main villain of the
Kang Dynasty now I don't think there's
really any spoilers or shock there we
all know that keng's not going anywhere
we know ant-man's not going to kill Kang
or all of the kings in quantumania
because we have a movie called The Kang
Dynasty coming up after but it is
important to note we'll meet the main
Kang in quantumania now moving into the
King Dynasty here here's one of the
reports that we have today coming from
our buddy Paul over at heavy spoilers
and Paul has been known to be accurate
with his information so here we go he
says that the Kang Dynasty ends with
Kang the same King from Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania conquering many worlds
and defeating our team of Avengers this
will then lead to Secret Wars where the
Avengers search the Multiverse for More
Heroes to help so basically what we have
here is kind of the same format of
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game the Kang Dynasty will end
essentially with the villain winning the
heroes losing and the next movie will be
about redemption or I should say them
avenging only this time instead of their
own Universe it's going to be many
different universes many different
worlds many different life forms
billions and billions of people that
they have to save now before we dive
deeper into this real quick I want to
mention doom and I want to mention Doom
because Doom hasn't actually been
mentioned there's been a lot of talk on
whether or not Dr Doom was supposed to
be in Blackpool Panther 2 or not whether
he's going to show up in Avengers Secret
Wars and possibly take the powers of
Kang or the beyonder like he does in the
secret Wars comics and unfortunately I
think we're leaning more and more
towards Doctor Doom not showing up in
the multiversal Saga and I hate to say
it and I'm super bummed about it however
I do think Dr Doom should probably have
his own Saga trust me I want Dr Doom to
appear it would be really cool if he
appeared in secret Wars but I don't
think he's a villain that should just
show up and then be gone if Dr Doom does
show up in secret Wars I hope he's a
variant of the main universe that way
when everything kind of goes back to
normal after Secret Wars or whatever the
norm will be after Secret Wars because
we know the MCU will change that's when
I want Dr Doom to come in and at that
time whoever's left on The Avengers and
the other Heroes will probably know to
look out for Doctor Doom if he is indeed
a villain in secret Wars but if not I
hope he gets an entire Saga dedicated to
him because he is a top 10 top five
probably possibly the best Marvel
villain there is but as of right now we
haven't really heard much about Doom
showing up in the Kang Dynasty or
Avengers Secret Wars but of course if we
hear anything we'll be sure to let you
know but back to the plots for the King
Dynasty in secret Wars much like
Avengers Infinity War where Thanos won
by snapping there is going to be a major
event where Kang defeats the Avengers
and ends up dominating and conquering
different worlds now what's also really
interesting about this is that there are
still two movies in between the Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars and if the team
is going to lose in the Kang Dynasty
that means the two movies in between are
going to be very very important Avengers
Infinity war and end game were back to
back but that won't exactly be the case
for the King Dynasty and Secret Wars but
let's talk about Secret Wars now in
secret Wars The Avengers are obviously
going to travel to other universes to
ask More Heroes for help this is where
things get truly amazing and this is
where the potential is literally
Limitless anything is literally possible
in this movie it's basically what we
hoped Doctor Strange was going to be
we're going to see our main Heroes
traveling throughout the Multiverse
going to other worlds talking to
variants of themselves and variants that
we probably haven't seen in our main
Universe yet so we are going to have a
multiversal Avengers team which is
really cool to think about now there are
a few different ways that they could
play this in secret Wars one is that all
of the different variants could come
together on one world and fight the main
King the Conqueror or two they could all
fight in their own universes and three
would be a combination of both which I
do think is going to happen because like
I mentioned in the beginning of this
video there aren't just going to be good
variants but there are going to be bad
variants as well and these variants are
going to be working for Kang and I
actually believe we could see some of
these variants show up in Ant-Man 3.
these variants could be variants of good
superheroes but could be evil themselves
remember not every variant has to be
good we saw an evil variant and Dr
strange and he is definitely not the
only evil variant out there and rumor
has it that some of these evil variants
are actually going to end up working for
King which makes sense we've already
seen that he has an army a really huge
Army so it would make sense that he
would have other people work for him
other villains who also want to conquer
and like they say if you can't beat him
join him which is probably the mentality
of all of these evil variants that we'll
see so I think Secret Wars will be a
combination of fights happening in
multiple worlds but then a giant huge
fight taking place in one Universe
against the main King the Conqueror and
this is The Big Show this is going to be
what is going to make Avengers Secret
Wars bigger than infinity War bigger
than end game bigger than anything this
is where we finally see variants of our
favorite characters fighting together
against Kang and possibly other variants
of our favorite characters but who are
evil and I do believe that if they pull
this off in the right way it will be
bigger than infinity war and end game
and I do like this style it does work I
like the idea of the villain winning in
the first movie and in the second movie
The Avengers avenge there are going to
be some similarities and it looks like
the quantum realm is indeed still going
to be a pretty big part however I do
think it'll be different because Mr
Fantastic will be in the MCU at this
point in time and perhaps he will
discover some form of time travel that
is much more controllable and could even
travel to different universes I think
the Fantastic Four are going to be an
extremely important part to both of
these films and to saving the entire
Multiverse the first time travel
technology that Kang actually finds is a
remnant of technology that Mr Fantastic
made and Nathaniel Richards AKA King the
Conqueror is believed to be a descendant
of Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic so
there will probably be a pretty cool
connection there as well but I for one
am just really excited to see all of the
different variants all of the different
worlds and universes and just see a huge
big multiversal Collision so I'm
definitely all for this this definitely
makes sense King the Conqueror is a
series is threat it would make sense
that he would win especially since his
technology seems to be a lot more
advanced than what we know right now so
him winning in the first movie makes
sense but of course the Avengers have to
avenge they have to come back and they
eventually have to win which is going to
happen in secret Wars however I do think
there will be some consequences but that
is for a different video in the meantime
let me know what you think about these
plot details in the comments down below
do you like this do you not let me know
and please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news and for
live updates you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf
foreign